nonprofits across the valley are still
coming together in support of ukraine
one local charity in spring valley has
made it their mission to supply feminine
products to women in need madison
kimbrough joins us live outside their
headquarters with the latest tonight
madison
yeah project maryland is just three
years old but they've already made quite
the impact here in vegas we're actually
inside of their headquarters and you can
take a look as they provide products
like pads feminine wipes and tampons to
women in need to fight period poverty
the non-profit has teamed up with baby's
bounty to send thousands of supplies
overseas to ukrainian refugees in poland
for those women who may not have access
to these items during this time of
crisis the goal is to send three to four
pallets of supplies over to poland in
the next coming weeks founder wendy
schweigard created the non-profit as a
way to honor her late mother and as she
saw a need in our community and now
plans to help women
overseas we're small
but we want to do what we can we want to
show the people of ukraine what a big
heart our hometown of las vegas southern
nevada has they're using tampons for
bullet wounds which i didn't know about
and is actually really
eye-opening of what's going on over
there so we're going to send tampons
we're going to send pads we're going to
send whatever we can
to help however we can over there
whatever the items are needed for
anyone who would like to donate to the
cause is more than welcome as you can
stop by and deliver individually wrapped
boxed products or donate to their link
that's up on their website now these
pallets that you're seeing right now are
set to be donated in the next coming
weeks as project maryland says they will
continue to donate as much as they can
as there continues to be a need overseas
we'll be live at six o'clock reporting
live inside of their headquarters
madison kimbrough live local now